m
et
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hémicycle où
la direction la rédaction d'antenne 2
ses invités ses correspondants vont tout
au long de la soirée vous faire vivre
ces élections européennes version 84 ces
élections ont partout en europe et en
france
valeur de test pour les formations
politiques
il y avait en france je vous le rappelle
14 listes en présence on se sent 34
candidats pour 81 sièges à pourvoir
alors tout de suite sans plus attendre
les résultats d'une opération de
sondages inédites jusqu'ici en france le
sondage le dv1 effectués à la sortie des
bureaux de vote albert du roy
alors nous allons voir apparaître sur
nos écrans les résultats pour les
principales listes voici la liste lille
georges marchais entre 11 et demi et
très et demi pour cent
la liste lionel jospin entre 24 21 et 24
% la liste simone veil -le entre 40,5 et
43 5%
voilà pour les trois grandes listes vous
savez qu'il y en avait 14 listes dans
cette élection
voici notre fourchette non pas pour
toutes les listes
mais pour les deux des principales
petite liste liste jean marie le pen
entre neuf et demi et 11 et demi pour
cent vous allez voir ce chiffre
apparaître sur votre écran et liste
olivier stirn entre deux et demi et 4 et
demi pour cent le total des autres liste
obtient entre six et demi et dix et demi
pour cent dans ce score évidemment la
liste des verts des écologistes ce sera
taillé probablement la part du lion
si ces résultats sont confirmés tout à
l'heure par notre opération estimation
on peut déjà noter christine une nette
percée de l'extrême droite une nouvelle
baisse du parti communiste
un score socialiste oscillant entre eux
pour l'instant le moyen et le médiocre
pour l'opposition rpr udf un chiffre
décevant par rapport à ses espoirs et
pour la tentative centriste stirn douba
lalonde une grosse déception
alors les urnes sens
et maintenant depuis un peu plus de
vingt minutes dans une demi heure à peu
près nous aurons l'estimation devenu
classique et hautement fiables
l'estimation les résultats à partir des
bulletins de vote réels
le rappel d'un chiffre à ne pas oublier
pour pondérer ces tendances le taux
d'abstention je vous le rappelle le taux
d'abstention aujourd'hui est estimé à
41% soit un peu plus qu'en 79
c'est la deuxième fois que les pays
membres de la communauté européenne
élisent des députés à strasbourg au
suffrage universel
on a voté aujourd'hui en france mais
aussi en allemagne fédérale en italie en
belgique en grèce et au luxembourg
les britanniques les irlandais les
hollandais les danois ont voté jeudi
dernier mais dans tous les pays de la
communauté
le dépouillement aura lieu ce soir
maintenant on expliquera tout à l'heure
le sens de ces élections à l'étranger
avec ses invités aussi nos
correspondants nous recevrons aussi bien
sur des personnalités politiques et paul
amar interrogera les chefs des
formations politiques sur leur
interprétation des résultats
des résultats qui je vous le rappelle
nous parviendrons de manière précise à
22h45
mais revenons déjà sur les premières
indications tout à fait intéressante que
nous ont fourni ce sondage à la sortie
des bureaux de vote patricia jean louis
nous allons vous présenter une nouvelle
fois donc les fourchettes pour les
grandes glisses réalisez vous le savez
grâce à des interviews exécuter toute la
journée à la sortie des bureaux de vote
la liste de georges marchais obtiendrait
donc entre 11 et demi et très et demi
pour cent la liste de lionel jospin
entre 21 et 24 % et la liste de simone
veil entre 40,5 et 43,5 pour cent voici
donc pour les trois grandes glisses vous
le savez il y avait quatorze lice pour
cette élection européenne reste donc
onze listes et tout autant de fourchette
réalisé donc grâce à nos interviews à la
sortie des bureaux de vote
nous allons vous présenter maintenant
les fourchettes pour la liste de
jean marie le pen le leader du front
national pour celle de la liste est
requis et vous le savez la liste de
stirn doubin lalonde et enfin pour les
autres petites listes alors le leader du
front national qui va s'inscrire dans
quelques secondes sur votre écran
j'espère la liste de jean marie le pen
donc obtiendrait entre neuf et demi et
aux ennemis % la liste de olivier stirn
c'est la première entre deux ennemis et
4 et demi pour cent la liste le pen
entre neuf et demi et aux ennemis % et
les autres listes entre six et demi et
10 ennemis pour ça alors ce sondage nous
permet patricia de nourrir et d'analyser
toutes sortes de tableau une première
comparaison intéressante si l'on reprend
la ventilation des électeurs à
l'élection présidentielle de 80 comment
les électeurs de françois mitterrand et
de valéry giscard d'estaing se sont ils
répartis cette fausse effectivement
christine c'est l'un des éléments
politiques essentielles et les plus
intéressants de la soirée il s'agissait
donc de savoir comment les électeurs qui
ont voté françois mitterrand en mai 1981
et valéry giscard d'estaing en 1981 on
votait aujourd'hui vous le voyez
s'inscrire sur votre écran sur 100
électeurs qui ont voté françois
mitterrand en mai 1981 aujourd'hui 25%
se sont prononcés pour georges marchais
47% pour lionel jospin 8% pour simone
veil et 6% pour jean marie le pen pour
valéry giscard d'estaing sur 100
électeurs dont qui ont voté pour lui aux
présidentielles 1% à voter georges
marchais 2%
lionel jospin 76% simone veil et 15%
jean marie le pen albert du roy en
premier commentaire sur ces comparaisons
oui ces chiffres sont particulièrement
éloquents et illustre bien
deux des principaux enseignements déjà
de cette soirée électorale qui commence
à peine d'une part on peut mesurer grâce
à ce tableau les le nombre d'e on ne
peut appeler les déçus du socialisme
on voit par exemple que 14 % des
électeurs de françois mitterrand en 81
qui ont voté aujourd'hui n'ont pas voté
pour les deux listes de gauche il y en a
qui ont voté pour simone veil 8% et il y
en a qui ont voté pour la liste jean
marie le pen 6%
c'est là vraiment ce qu'on peut appeler
on a appelé les déçus du socialisme de
à quoi il faut probablement ajouter un
certain nombre d'électeurs de gauche qui
se sont abstenus aujourd'hui puisque
l'abstention vous le rappeler a été
supérieure à celle de 1979 deuxième
enseignement on voit clairement la
tentation de l'extrême droite et du
durcissement de l'opposition non
seulement à gauche puisqu'il ya des
électeurs de françois mitterrand qui ont
voté le pen mais surtout dans
l'opposition où il y à 15% des électeurs
qui avaient voté
giscard d'estaing en 81 et qui ont
reporté leurs suffrages aujourd'hui
nettement plus à droite sur la liste de
jean marie le pen
alors rené rémond justement cette percée
sans précédent de l'extrême droite
quelle signification lui donnez vous à
cette poussée de la liste conduite par
jean marie le pen est assurément un des
faits qui retiennent le plus l'attention
le succès passe la tente car on se
demandait si jean marie le pen
réussirait à franchir la barre des 5%
or non seulement il l'a franchie
puisqu'il va probablement entraîner avec
lui à strasbourg 8 ou 9 de ceux qui
figurent sur sa liste
mais il n'est pas loin de combler ses
voeux qui était de faire jeu égal avec
le parti communiste
si les indications que nous avons sont
fiables le parti communiste sera séparée
par trois points et pas davantage du
front national mais je vous rappelle que
nous raisonnons dont bien sûr les
résultats d'un sondage est que s'il ne
s'agit pas encore des estimations à
partir des bulletins de vote très
l'estimation que nous aurons donc à
22h45 le succès surfant d'autant plus
l'opinion que l'extrême droite avait
disparu depuis 20 ans depuis 1965 depuis
que tixier vignancour est tenue 5% de
suffrages alors que je signe ici
cette percée est ce un vote conservateur
réactionnaire libérale voire fascistes
si on considère les thèmes et les motifs
pour lesquels ont voté les électeurs de
jean marie le pen y assurément des
thèmes qui sont d'extrême droite
l'attrait de la personnalité c'est jean
marie le pen qui a le plus exercer une
attraction plus que les nageuses pas où
simone veil la sécurité néanmoins le
thème des libertés vient bien avant le
thème des des immigrés honnêtement je
vous interromps parce que nous avons
justement à notre disposition un tableau
qui nous permet de visualiser les
motivations des électeurs de jean-marie
le pen
un tableau que vous allez voir dans
quelques instants apparaître sur votre
écran quand il se recharge l'est oui
nous allons faire maintenant en fonction
de quels thèmes se sont prononcés les
électeurs de jean marie le pen est bien
sur 100 électeurs de jean marie le pen
41% ont considéré comme prioritaire vous
le voyez le thème des libertés 25 %
celui des immigrés 24% l'insécurité et
18% l'emploi nous voyons maintenant
apparaître les autres thèmes qui ont
compté pour ses électeurs l'école 14%
l'europe 12% le pouvoir d'achat 10% les
impôts 6%
enfin les inégalités 7% voilà je vous
propose maintenant d'entendre tout de
suite la rédaction la réaction de madame
simone veil madame simone veil auprès de
laquelle se trouve jean louis le scène
la déclaration de madame v dont feraient
d'abord remercier très chaleureusement
les électrices et les électeurs qui nous
ont apporté leur suffrage
et comme vous venez de l'entendre ils
ont été fort nombreux
alors qu'il est nous ne connaissons que
des résultats encore très partiels
d'après les sondages unique non et donc
avec l'imprécision que comporte toujours
ces tests et je crois qu'il serait
imprudent d'en tirer trop tôt tout
l'analyse qui pourra être fait dans la
nuit ou demain matin
il semble cependant et je crois qu'on
peut le dire sans trop s'aventurer
compte tenu du fait que ces sondages
sont assez convergents que d'ores et
déjà il apparaît que la liste d'union de
l'opposition devant ce de façon tout à
fait considérable l'ensemble de la liste
des 2 lys du parti communiste et du
parti socialiste
c'est bien là l'objectif que nous nous
étions fixés
et je dirais même au delà dans la
distance qui est ainsi apparaît ainsi
dès aujourd'hui je crois que pour le
reste maintenant il nous faut attendre
d'avoir des résultats précis et de
pouvoir en tirer les conclusions pour ce
scrutin pour le parlement européen en
dénombrant le nom les élus de chacune
des listes et notamment pour la nôtre ce
sera certainement un nombre important et
aussi pour la politique française
je vous remercie voilà madame veil je
vous le rappelle d'après notre sondage à
la sortie des bureaux de vote madame
veil a recueilli entre 45 et 43,5 pour
cent des votes dans un peu moins d'un
quart d'heure maintenant nous aurons la
première estimation des résultats à
partir des bulletins de vote réels
venons en aux motivations des électeurs
dans cette élection car je vous le
rappelle c'est l'intérêt est l'origine
et l'originalité de notre dispositif
nous pouvons tout au long de la soirée
expliquer de façon précise et imagé
pourquoi les français ont voté comme ils
l'ont fait alors un premier constat
patries charnelles et les motivations
nationales l'ont largement emporté sur
les motivations europe est absolument
christine la question posée était en
effet avez vous voté en pensant d'abord
à la france où d'abord à l'europe
et bien vous allez voir que sur 100
électeurs une majorité 55% exactement
ont voté en pensant à la situation
intérieure de la france 41 % ont voté à
eux en pensant d'abord à l'europe ce
résultat était prévisible les
préoccupations nationales non bien sûr
emporté sur le débat européen
reste que le score européen n'est tout
de même pas négligeable
il n'est pas négligeable et partout
dans les dix pays membres de la
communauté on a donc voté pour désigner
les représentants à l'assemblée de
strasbourg est partout paul nahon de ce
sont bien les préoccupations nationales
qui l'ont emporté
effectivement christine dans les autres
pays de la communauté européenne comme
en france d'ailleurs cette élection a
d'abord été un test national pour les
équipes au pouvoir les électeurs ont
bien senti que si l'europe existaient
vraiment cette europe son parlement
européen ne disposer d'aucun pouvoir
réel d'aucun pouvoir législatif
bref en un mot pas de supra nationalité
tout au long de la soirée avec nos
différents correspondant à bruxelles
l'undd rome bonne et dans les autres
villes d'europe
nous essaierons de dégager la
signification de ce vote aussi bien sur
le plan local que sur le plan européen
avec également des commentaires des
journalistes européens en poste à paris
présents sur ce plateau tout au long de
la soirée et que j'interrogerai premiers
invités diana guedes du times de londres
j'aimerais vous demander tout de suite
si ce vote si le vote en angleterre
risque de modifier la politique de rama
thatcher pas parce que selon les
sondages on n'a pas encore les résultats
définitifs bien sûr madame thatcher a
perdu 3,5 pour cent à la typo législatif
en juin l'année pas te fait penser c'est
pas tellement important pour elle même
si le parti travailliste a beaucoup en
planter effectivement d'après un sondage
effectué vendredi parce que vous le
savez les britanniques votée vendredi
dernier à la sortie des bureaux de vote
en grande bretagne et travail seraient
les acteurs de cette élection européen
et c'est à dire contre le parti
conservateur le parti devenant thatcher
tout de suite à londres philippe
harrouard les choses vont assez
lentement ici en grande bretagne
le décompte des voix a commencé assez
tard il est vrai qu'il y à une heure de
décalage par rapport à la france
et pourtant vous savez qu'on a voté ici
jeudi dernier il faut donc se baser
uniquement pour l'instant sur des
estimations qui ont été faites
immédiatement après le vote de jeudi
dernier la participation aurait été
faible 30% environ c'est moins que la
dernière fois
en ce qui concerne les sièges les
travaillistes faisant effectivement une
belle percée puisque il gagnerait entre
14 et tessier
au parlement de strasbourg les
travaillistes font partie à strasbourg
du groupe socialiste les conservateurs
le parti de madame thatcher perdrait
également entre 14 et 16 sièges mais il
conserverait la majorité des sièges
en ce qui concerne les voies la
comparaison se fait avec les dernières
élections législatives
celle de 1983 puisque ici comme ailleurs
ces élections permettent surtout de
mesurer les forces politiques au plan
national
alors les travaillistes gagneraient 8
points les conservateurs en perdrait à
peu près 4 ce qui serait un mauvais
résultat pour madame thatcher est un bon
score pour le parti travailliste qui a
mis l'accent dans sa campagne sur le
mécontentement des britanniques à
l'égard du gouvernement
mais encore une fois ce ne sont que des
estimations les résultats un peu plus
tard voilà donc pour la grande bretagne
en allemagne fédérale peuls ont voté
comme en france aujourd'hui on votait
aujourd'hui j'ai déjà les premières
estimations de ce vote en allemagne de
l'ouest je vous les donne très
rapidement pour la cd ou à savoir le
parti du chancelier kohl ou pouvoir 45%
pour l'opposition spd à savoir du
chancelier schmidt ou de monsieur willy
brandt 38,8 pour cent soit 32 sièges au
parlement européen les libéraux
le fdp de monsieur ben cheikh 5,5 pour
cent et les verts 7,7 pour cent mais il
s'agit toujours d'estimations à mes
côtés monsieur von kaennel du journal
die welt de bonnes apparemment ce
sondage ne gêneront pas monsieur pour le
pouvoir n'ont certainement pas demain
que à main que le très mauvais résultats
du parti ftp l'hiver elle puisse mettre
à la langue en danger ça colle et je
vous le rappelle 5,5 contre et on chesil
enlevé de la barre juste juste là bas
n'est ce pas et tout à l'heure j'étais
vrai qu'un collègue à bonn qui m'a dit
il s'attaque en train de trembler parce
qu'il savait pas très bien si elle
faisait les franchir au nom cette
célèbre bas par contre les verts
demandent sans cesse d'enfler pellen
leenders 7,7 c'est qui peut être
éventuellement à la langue une
transformation profonde de la scène post
également est ce que la coalition peut
éclater à cause des des libéraux de
monsieur venture non je crois pas jeudi
durant certains jusqu'au terme de la
dégustation
mais à la longue le parti est
effectivement la vie à partie pour ainsi
dire presque condamnés
merci nous nous retrouvons tout de suite
à bonn michel meyer michel meyer cette
oeuvre
michel meyer en allemagne une
participation à la mesure d'une campagne
électorale plutôt médiocre à savoir les
électeurs ne se sont pas pressés devant
les urnes
une participation de quelques 55 % des
électeurs contre 67% en 79 alors comment
s'en sortent les partis politiques
après cette consultation est bien les
chiffres sont assez claires la
chrétienne démocratie du chancelier kohl
est en légère perte 46% des voix le
parti d'opposition le parti de vie libre
and social démocrate est en position
plus stable 37% des voix selon les
ordinateurs les grands partis se
tiennent donc en respect par contre des
fêtes semi défaite des libéraux de genk
cher qui perdent des voix mais qui passe
malgré tout est presque miraculeusement
la barre des 5% avec 5,2 pour cent des
voix seulement résultats intéressants
qui pourraient éventuellement si la
barre des 5% n'est pas franchie par les
libéraux ce qui peut se dire à l'heure
actuelle avoir des conséquences
intérieures succès attendu des verts des
écologistes et pacifistes allemands
il passe la barre des 5% avec 7,8 pour
cent des voix confirmation donc de ce
parti sur la scène politique intérieure
allemande sinon sur la scène européenne
voici donc les résultats d'une élection
assez
calme sans passion et résultats sans
surprise voilà à terre en paix
maintenant sept cette tournée des
capitales européennes car jean marie le
pen le président du front national est
présent sur le plateau parmi nous je
vous rappelle monsieur le pen que les
résultats du sondage effectué par bull
bébé à tout au long de la journée pour
antennes de radio monte carlo et le
parisien libéré ce sondage vous donne
une fourchette des voies entre 9,5 et
11,5 pour cent des voix pour vous c'est
une surprise
pas du tout c'est le chiffre que j'avais
à plusieurs reprises annoncé comme étant
celui que j'espérais j'avais un espoir
supplémentaire je veux dire c'était de
battre le parti communiste mais ce sera
pour la prochaine fois mais je crois que
nous ne sommes pas loin de lui et je
bien sûr suis ému de ce résultat et j'en
remercie et je remercie toutes les
électrices et les électeurs qui nous ont
fait cette grande confiance et tout
particulièrement ceux qui ont combattu
qui ont lutté tous ces militants qui
sont dévoués au service d'une les
petites listes comme on disait à
l'époque grévé de tous les handicaps
légaux qui a disposé de trois minutes de
télévision officielle c'est à dire en
fait de 2 20 à 100 fois moins que ses
grands concurrents à cause des retombées
que ces émissions et les émissions
officielles on dans la presse écrite
radios diffusées ou télévisées elle-même
mais que d'autres pas je voudrais
ajouter que ces trois grandes villes se
sont partagé 3 milliards de centimes que
leur avait accordé l'assemblée
européenne et que nos réunions ont été
tout uniment l'objet tout au long de la
campagne d'une attaque de dénigrement
auquel il faut bien se dire se sont
malheureusement juin quelquefois les
candidats de l'opposition parlementaire
monsieur le pen on apprend grâce au
sondage que nous avons réalisé que la
plupart de vos électeurs ont voté pour
vous parce que ils craignent pour les
libertés en france
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu gros est
ce que ses électeurs n'ont pas été dans
une certaine mesure
même s'ils sont de bonne foi berne et
c'est toujours le prix noailles or nous
voyons ce sont les opérateurs
nous voyons en ce moment donc le rappel
des motivations de vos électeurs
monsieur le pen on constate en effet que
41 % d'entre eux se sont déterminés sur
le thème des libertés alors qu'est ce
que vous aviez justement c'est parce
qu'ils pensent que je suis un défenseur
des libertés
comment se vêtit quel impact uation
faut-il aux observateurs politiques et
aux politologues pour toujours croire
que ce sont eux qui ont raison contre le
peuple sont faits l'association leurs
préjugés qui doivent l'emporter sur la
réalité il se trouve que j'ai été décrit
comme l'immonde et spa comme la bête
comme le diable et bien il se trouve que
les français qui l'avait qui avait déjà
démontré dans le pays où je suis né
qu'il me donnait à 51 % leurs voix ne
pense pas du tout comme les journalistes
ni comme les observateurs politiques
il pense que les libertés sont menacées
non pas par monsieur le pen mais par le
communisme
ils pensent que l'immigration que le
chômage que l'insécurité sont des
problèmes réels et que le pen dit haut
ce que tout le monde pense tout bas je
le sais ce qu'ils ont voulu dire mais je
les en remercie
et ils peuvent me faire confiance ce
n'est que la première étape d'une longue
course qui ira jusqu'à relais la
renaissance française ce n'est qu'un
début
ce n'est qu'un début monsieur le pen
vous avez fait campagne sur des thèmes
qui exacerbe qui dure six qui divise au
lieu de rassembler ce que vous n'avez
pas pris calmement est ce que vous
n'avez pas pris un risque considérable
mais pas du tout ce sont des problèmes
qui se posent
j'intervenais spa à un peuple n'est pas
seulement une machine à calculer et le
on ne gère pas son avenir
exclusivement comme une affaire
commerciale un peuple c'est un être
collectif qui a des passions des
émotions et répulsion qui a des
espérances et des désespoirs et le rôle
de des hommes politiques qui mérite ce
nom et qui n'en font pas seulement un
métier c'est d'interpréter tout cela est
de mettre tout cela dans une forme
compréhensible à la grande masse
monsieur le fait de proposer des
solutions qui soient des solutions
réelles
réaliste qui répondent à la gravité des
problèmes posés ce n'est pas moi qui ai
créé le problème de l'immigration
mais je m'honore d'avoir été le premier
à l'avoir posée devant l'opinion
publique et à avoir forcés chacun à
prendre sur ce sujet ses responsabilités
monsieur le pen vous êtes dans
l'opposition opposition radicale la
liste d'union de l'opposition menée par
simone veil n'obtient pas ce soir la
majorité absolue souhaitez vous que ce
soit on additionne vos voix à celle de
la liste de simone veil et côté de toute
évidence les électeurs de madame veil et
les miens les additionne rond même si
les spécialistes ne le font pas
l'opposition a gagné et elle a gagné
grâce à l'opposition nationale la nôtre
qui a été non seulement le fer de lance
mais l'aiguillon de l'opposition
parlementaire qui est souvent il faut
bien le dire à notre avis complaisante
puisque récemment encore elle votait à
l'unanimité l'attribution de la carte
des aux immigrés pour dix ans n'est ce
pas ce qui prouve qu'ils s'entendent
entre eux et je que je crois une des
grandes leçons
un portage crois que nous vivons un
événement politique très très important
aujourd'hui c'est la défaite de la
gauche la gauche dans ce pays non
seulement est minoritaire
mais le gouvernement représente 1 1 sur
3 des français il ne peut donc plus
continuer à gouverner comme il le
faisait ni à faire sous couvert de la
loi
une véritable révolution marxiste et
pour ma part je crois que il faudrait
envisager que le pays ait pu consulter
d'une autre manière peut-être que sont
celles qui sont habituelles à notre pays
je me demande si sur les grands sujets
des libertés en particulier la liberté
de l'enseignement la liberté de la
presse
il ne faudrait pas envisager les moyens
de recourir à la procédure référendaire
moi je ne prends que il faut il faut
envisager des transformations
constitutionnel dans notre pays pour
l'adapter à la période moderne et je
crois que nous venons de vivre la fin
sont tout ce n'est pas à propos
révolutionnaires mais la fin de la 5ème
république à gré de la bande des quatre
monsieur le pen et imaginons que nous
soyons en 86 l'opposition au premier
tour en port
le succès vous remportez le même succès
qu'aujourd'hui allez-vous monnayer vos
voix pour le second tour et je ne
n'avais jamais mais voit d'abord vous
affirmez qui va y avoir un second tour
est de toute évidence il n'y en aura pas
quoi qu'en pense laurent de l'hypothèse
de 86,9 écossais andy robinson les
européennes
je parle de 86 et moi je vous dis en 86
et je suis prêt à prendre le pari que
j'avais pris sur la liste unique à
prendre le pari que j'avais pris sur le
chiffre de plus de 10% pour le futur le
front national les prochaines élections
législatives auront lieu
de toute évidence au scrutin
proportionnel en dit vous seriez élus
autrement dit vous et votre sens députés
comme ça une centaine de députés
une centaine de députés c'est un chiffre
que l'on peut inscrire vos pronostics
pour 86 des répondants je tiens je
soutiens ce soutien le barème j'ose dire
pourquoi mais n'oublie pas du tout tu
peux te régulier à bord de ce cuirassé
le coeur contre les grandes espérances
et on finit par se le cuirassé aussi
contre les grandes joies et les grandes
victoires
je suis très modéré beaucoup plus que ne
l'affirment généralement dans les
tribunes politiques parce que c'est
l'humain des règles dans 30 langues et
orient avant politique
non j'ai une expérience politique voyons
c'est très simple il ya 35 % de voix à
gauche au scrutin dont 20 et 15 ou 20 et
13 33 si on allait au scrutin
majoritaire avec ces chiffres là ils
reviendraient 25 députés socialo
communiste alors de toute évidence avait
pas le système qui va être choisi
alors que si on prend le système
proportionnel à 20 et 15 35%
ils reviennent au moins 150 alors croyez
bien que le système qui sera pris procès
le doyen vedène qui disait il n'y a
qu'un seul bon système électoral c'est
celui qui vous fait élire c'est ce
qu'ont toujours pensé les gouvernements
mais il est évident qu'ils ne vont pas
faire de confidences à personne avant de
le choisir et le président de la
république choisira son jour son heure
pour imposer pour faire voter par sa
majorité
le système électoral qui sera le moins
tragique pour la gauche
monsieur le pen c'est l'alternance
réussit un jour vous souhaiteriez siéger
au conseil des ministres côtés de
jacques chirac vous de ballerines
cabestan même de simone veil
à l'égard de laquelle nous sommes est
très indulgent ce soir mais je ne fais
pas de prospective politique de ce genre
je note un certain nombre de faits la
défaite cinglante de la gauche et la
france le pays a montré que nonobstant
les institutions et le cadre dans lequel
on prétendait l'interroger c'est lui qui
donnait la réponse et qui posait le
problème on l'interrogeait sur une
élection européenne d'une assemblée le
consulte-t-il il a répondu à des
questions de politique intérieure c'est
lui c'est le peuple français qui a dit
voilà ce dont je veux parler et ce dont
je veux parler
c'est un démenti à des aveux formelle de
la politique marxiste
je crois l'avoir pour ma part entendu
ainsi sans cela il est évident que le
succès obtenu par le front national
n'aurait pas la dimension
notons au passage pour les politologues
que c'est la première fois qu'un courant
réussi à percer le blindage le blindage
privilégié monopolis de la bande des
quatre
lesquels se sont toujours tout de même
mais par nec mais quels partenaires se
sont toujours à ranger dans le fond pour
se renvoyer agréablement et utilement la
balle monsieur le pen ya quand même un
mot que vous n'avez pas prononcé dans
tout ça c'est le mot europe
alors maintenant que vous êtes assurés
d'envoyer un certain nombre de députés à
strasbourg maintenant aussi je vous
rappelle que le parlement européen va
vous rembourser une partie de vos frais
électoraux puisque vous semblez faire
plus de 5%
est ce que à la tribune de la grande
bouffe cruz allez vous allez tenir un
langage aussi musclé que celui qu'on a
pu entendre en france pendant la
campagne électorale je pense notamment
aux droits de l'homme mais il me paraît
toujours que la santé implique que l'on
soit musclé c'est quand on manque de
muscles comme est sur le point de tomber
malade et c'est le reproche d'ailleurs
que je fais à notre pays
la force n'est pas la violence qu'il en
est que son expression injuste
la force est une vertu et je souhaite
que la france soit forte il me paraît
même que c'était le slogan de nos
concurrents je crois et il tirait la
conclusion que quand la france est forte
l'europe est aussi et bien c'est un
point sur lequel je suis en
or avec ses concurrents mais je crois
que rien ne se fera parce que la france
est la france parce que la france en
europe a un rôle particulier à jouer et
ce n'est pas fait réagir aux autres pays
que de le dire qu'ils ont rempli leur
rôle dans l'histoire de l'europe la
france a un rôle je crois missionné et
tout dépendra de sa renaissance de son
aptitude à renaître et a perduré et je
crois que c'est à elle que le défi est
lancé et c'est elle qui doit y répondre
non seulement pour elle-même non
seulement pour l'europe mais même pour
la paix du monde et et pour la faim dans
le monde d'hier la france aux français
non ce n'est pas has le gain du front
national le slogan du front national
c'est les français d'abord des français
d'abord en france les européens
d'abord en europe et puis autrement dit
que chacun puisse travailler au pij
obstacle le banc qui n'appartenait pas
spécialement au front national qui
appartenait même je crois à une
formation politique
là c'est sensiblement t'opposer monsieur
le pen je vous remercie je vous propose
maintenant de revenir à la dimension
européenne de ce scrutin et de reprendre
notre tournée des capitales européennes
passons en italie paul nahon justin nous
partons de france pour aller en italie
et j'ai à mes côtés sur ce plateau
monsieur bernardo valli correspondant du
quotidien la stampa de turin
bernardo valli est ce que le parti
communiste italien peut bénéficier si
j'ose dire de l'effet de la mer de
béring heures pour arriver premier dans
les sondages
oui allianz est en panne vous cédez
l'extrême droite mais une d'un succès du
parti communiste qui tous les dépasser
d'après les prévisions la démocratie
chrétienne pour la première fois depuis
la naissance de la république
bernardo valli on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure nous retrouvons maintenant à
rome victor vraiment et je vous rappelle
qu'en 79 l'italie a détenu le record de
la participation électorale avec 86 % de
votants victor vraiment c'est à vous
apprendre allemands les italiens restent
les meilleurs électeurs d'europe
le taux de participation est tout à fait
comparable à celui de 1979
près de 86 % de votants il y aurait une
petite baisse dans le sud de l'italie ce
qui apparemment n'arrangerait pas les
affaires de la démocratie chrétienne
kirk est toujours le plus grand nombre
de ses voix au sud d'oman avec la
mitaine en italie comme ailleurs ces
élections européennes se transforme
forcément en une manifestation de
soutien aux projets du gouvernement en
place ici on voit le président du
conseil bettino craxi qui a voté à milan
toute la campagne électorale a été
dominée par les tiraillements et les
frictions à l'intérieur de la majorité
gouvernementale
surtout lorsqu'un socialiste a accusé le
démocrate-chrétien julian dreyer aussi
d'avoir été le grand inspirateur de la
loge maçonnique p2 ou var culte et
malfaisant les grandes options
européennes des partis politiques ont
certainement eu très peu d'impact sur
les électeurs la preuve il n'y a qu'une
chose qui intéresse la classe politique
est ce que cette fois ci le parti
communiste réussira à dépasser la
démocratie chrétienne
et à devenir le premier parti politique
italien du moins à l'occasion ces
élections européennes l'instant peu de
turan a publié un dessin on voit un
fourgon mortuaire essayant de dépasser
une voiture dans laquelle se trouve le
numéro un de la démocratie chrétienne
des mythes dans le fourgon mortuaire
il y a évidemment la dépouille d'enrico
berlinguer c'est l'une des inconnues de
ce scrutin est ce que la mort d'enrico
berlinguer va créer un mouvement de
sympathie et de quelle ampleur autour du
pc en tout cas et alors qu'il est la
seule certitude c'est que les italiens
sont restés fidèles à leur réputation
les aime bien voter voilà merci victor
va vraiment nous terminerons par
bruxelles ce tour européen bruxelles où
daniel braid va nous donner les
premières estimations pour les pays bas
le luxembourg et la belgique daniel ici
au parlement européen de bruxelles on
cultive les symboles mais on navigue en
recherchant le plus souvent sur les
chaînes de télévision des pays de la
communauté les premières estimations
les premiers sondages connus ou sont
arrivés de l'udc semblons pas de
changement trois sièges pour les
chrétiens-sociaux de siège sans
changement pour les libéraux et un siège
pour les socialistes
aux pays-bas il s'agit là encore
d'estimation 9 sièges pour les chrétiens
démocrates perdent une saint siège pour
les libéraux gagnent 1 8 sièges pour les
socialistes perdent une un siège pour le
parti protestant là sans changement le
courant écologiste disparaît au profit
du courant pacifiste et communistes qui
gagne lui de siège en belgique 7 sièges
socialistes sans changement neuf
chrétiens démocrates moins-15 libéraux
+1 pour les trois autres sièges c'est
encore un distincts on le voit donc dans
la plupart des pays européens et une
érosion des partis au pouvoir de mme
encore pendant deux mois encore d'un
pays qui a voté aussi aujourd'hui la
grèce et là c'est particulièrement
intéressant parce que c'était le premier
test électoral depuis que monsieur
papandréou a pris le pouvoir il ya deux
ans et demi absolument c'était le
premier test électoral pour la grèce
nous n'avons pas encore d'indication
mais je vous rappelle
une précision importante le
était obligatoire en grèce la deuxième
question c'est pour le danemark
le danemark je vous le rappelle a voté
jeudi dernier et très forte abstention
au danemark
là aussi pas encore de résultats alors
revenons aux résultats du sondage à la
sortie des bureaux de vote
un sondage qui vous concernent aussi
monsieur douba je rappelle que vous êtes
l'une des trois têtes de la liste r
une liste qui n'est crédité d'après ce
sondage que de 2,5 à 4,5 pour cent des
voix alors c'est plutôt de l'air frais
pour vous à écouter je préfère penser
que nous sommes aux alentours de 4 c'est
un peu ce qui lui revient par ailleurs
alors bien sûr je suis déçu que nous
n'allions pas à l'assemblée européenne
d'autant plus que tout notre programme
toute cette campagne a été européenne
c'est ce qui nous a motivé le plus mais
faire 4 % ou trois et demi pour cent
mais je pense plutôt 4 c'est quand même
un bon résultat pour une alliance qui
vient de se créer et dont tout le monde
avait dit au départ qu'elle était trop
composites pour aller loin vous n'êtes
pas perçu comme un politicien vous êtes
connus et vous parlait déjà comme les
hommes politiques vous n'obtenez pas 5%
et me dit c'est un bon résultat
soyons francs c'est un échec c'est un
échec parce que nous ne passons pas la
barre des 5
mais en deux mois de campagne arrivé à
4% alors que tous vous tous au départ
vous disiez mais comment comment
pouvez-vous faire entre monsieur steven
qui vient de l'opposition vous qui est
de la majorité le monsieur lalonde qui
est écologiste comment pouvez vous vous
entendez vous voyez bien on s'est bien
entendu hees a convaincu quand même
beaucoup de français parce que pour
arriver à 4 il faut quand même faire des
bois pour arriver à 25.4 c'est pour
l'instant une fourchette
je sais mais enfin vous n'êtes vous
savez qu'à d'autres estimations que que
les vôtres et les autres sont plutôt
vers le haut de la fourchette que vous
indiquez qu'allez-vous faire demain vous
allez vous même
retourner au bercail réintégrer la mer'
j'ai quitté stirn qui va rejoindre
l'opposition quinzaine absolument
continuons nous l'avons dit pendant la
campagne le quelle manière je pense
exactement comme nous avons commencé je
crois qu'il est important à l'heure
actuelle est précisément parce que c'est
difficile de tenir un langage modéré
pour tenir un langage modéré dans ce
pays aujourd'hui il faut être courageux
c'est tellement plus facile de hurler
avec les loups et d'ailleurs je vous
fais remarquer que ça fait vingt ans que
ça dure ça fait 20 ans que ce sont les
extrêmes qui délivrent des brevets de
bonne conduite politique
eh bien nous disons au contraire que
l'avenir de ce pays c'est dans un retour
à la modération et au courage qui
consiste à ne pas à ne pas aller
immédiatement ou vers la gauche ou vers
à droite parce que ça n'est pas vrai que
quand on n'est pas de gauche on doive
être de droite et ça n'est pas vrai que
quand on n'est pas droite on doit
automatiquement être de gauche
il ya une place pour des gens qui au
centre développe un programme original
vous dites il ya une place il y aura
peut-être une place mais actuellement
cette place si elle est occupée par jean
marie le pen qui vous a précédé qui lui
tient un discours beaucoup plus dure et
qui a convaincu des français beaucoup
plus nombreux que les veaux oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai monsieur le pen gagne ce
soir et je le déplore parce
qu'effectivement pour tous ceux qui ne
veulent plus des grands blocs bay avait
le choix entre le pen et nous et c'est
vrai que le langage qu'il appelle musclé
et que moi j'appelle extrémistes et
passait mieux cette fois ci que le
langage plus modéré qu est le nôtre
seulement je suis désolé on verra tout
ça se voit à l' usage et vous savez bien
que ce qui est extrême et stérile eux il
est stérile de dire pour les contres
tout ce qu'on est contre ceci qu'on
l'ait contre cela qu'on veut ce qu'on
veut tous eu m parthenay nous disons au
contraire qu'il y a dans ce pays
il y a tous les éléments pour la
réussite et qu'il suffit d'un petit
quelque chose il suffit que les français
se remettent au travail suite les
français croient à nouveau à leur
démocratie pour que tout reparte
quelques pauses pour cela il n'est pas
nécessaire encore une fois de recourir à
des méthodes musclées
faut-il additionner vos voix à celles de
la gauche ce soir vous est dû à émerger
mrg fait partie de l'alliance de gauche
il ya deux ministres radicaux de gauche
au sein du gouvernement
que faut-il faire de vos voix écoutez il
ya des voix qui se sont portées sur
olivier stirn ya des voix qui se sont
portées sur brice lalonde il ya des voix
qui sont portés sur moi je suis
incapable de vous dire la proportion est
en tout état de cause ces voix ont très
clairement voulu dire qu'elle n'allait
ni n'a ni à droite ni à gauche qu'elle
se portait sur air qui était une liste
contre la bipolarisation qui
s'opposaient à la bipolarisation alors
toute manoeuvre qui consisterait à les
redécouvrir les réaffecter me paraît
aller contre la volonté même des
électeurs
messieurs de bas vous semblez vous
sembler un peu déçu à juste titre que
qu'il n'y ait pas eu plus de français
pour pour être sensible à la tonalité de
votre discours baisse qui se serait pas
le moment de faire un peu d'autocritique
et et de vous dire que peut-être sept
cette innovation que vous vouliez
apporté dans le langage politique
français elle n'était peut-être pas
aussi évidente
peut-être que nous n'avons pas su la
faire passer pour qu'elles paul qantas
et au fait qu'elle soit ou non fondées
là je suis persuadé qu'elle est fondée
et que ça se verra de plus en plus parce
que le problème de la bipolarisation ça
n'est pas de dire qu'on est contre le
fait que les françaises dépassent se
séparant de bouriane ya deux
sensibilités il ya une sensibilité
droite et de gauche
ce que nous disons c'est que deux
sensibilités on est passé au camp
retranché
et que ces deux camps retranchés sont
devenus totalement stérile qu'est ce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui de la vie
politique
souvenez vous de cette campagne quelles
sont les propositions réellement
concrète qui sont sortis des deux blocs
or les nôtres qui avons essayé d'en
faire beaucoup sur le plan de l'europe
or peut-être celle de deux petites
listes ou que l'on tient pour petit mais
moi j'essaie de me souvenir ce qui est
sorti du lot du grand face à face entre
madame weil le monsieur jeux spa ou de
celui entre monsieur pons et monsieur
marché je ne me souviens de rien et je
pense que les français ne se souviennent
de rien non plus et c'est comme un peu
triste sur une élection européenne
le seul résultat ce soit de dire eh bien
voilà comment se situe l'opposition par
rapport à la majorité
c'est comme ça que la france veut entrer
dans l'europe c'est en se divisant
encore plus soit en affichant sa
division que nous français nous allons
être capables de nous unir avec d'autres
européens
moi je déplore le ton et
tour qu'a pris cette élection monsieur
du bas merci vous nous rappeler à juste
titre que cette élection avait
essentiellement pour but d'envoyer de
désigner 80 députés français à
l'assemblée de strasbourg
une assemblée qui se réunit une fois par
mois à strasbourg dont le secrétariat
permanent est à luxembourg ce qui veut
dire que tous les mois 600
fonctionnaires et des tonnes de papier
des ménages pour aller de luxembourg à
strasbourg que les comités de cette
assemblée européenne s'est jetée à
bruxelles je vous rappelle aussi que les
indemnités parlementaires des députés
qui ont donc été désignés aujourd'hui
dans dix pays européens ces députés sont
versées par les états membres
l'assemblée de strasbourg on l'a dit
tout au long de cette campagne dès lors
on a parlé de l'europe l'assemblée de
strasbourg a de vrais pouvoirs le
pouvoir de rejeter le budget de la
communauté et le pouvoir de renvoyer
enveloppe les membres de la commission
ce dont elle n'a pas fait usage
jusqu'ici revenons cependant au n'ont
pas encore tout à fait aux estimations
si nous les avons à l'instant les
estimations donc des résultats à partir
des bulletins de vote réel cette fois du
lait d'hévéa sont maintenant en mesure
de nous les donner patricia jean noël
pour les grands buffets
oui pour les quatre grandes ligues
appréhender voici donc les résultats les
plus attendus de la soirée est bien
georges marchais obtiendrait 10,8 pour
cent des voix vous allez voir dans une
seconde s'inscrire sur votre écran
georges marchais donc 10,8
lionel jospin obtiendrait 20,8
simone veil 41,8 et jean marie le pen
10,8 pour cent des voix des résultats
que vous êtes déjà en mesure albert du
roy de comparer pour chaque grande liste
avec l'élection présidentielle de 80
mais peut-être que d'abord il faudrait
revenir sur ces quelques chiffres que
nous venons double mais parce que s'il
s'agit bien d'un événement politique et
même plusieurs événements lors du tir
voyons les
chien la liste communiste dans l'état
actuel de notre estimation est la liste
le pen
la liste d'extrême droite obtiennent le
même score 10,8 pour cent des voix c'est
évidemment un événement politique s'il
est confirmé par les résultats tout à
l'heure un événement politique
considérable dans la vie politique
française
prenons les listes maintenant l'une
après l'autre la liste communiste 10,8
pour cent il est évident que pour le
parti communiste c'est un résultat très
mauvais qui va au delà de tout ce qu'il
pouvait craindre et qui est une chute
correspondant à celle déjà très
importante qu'il avait subie entre
l'année de 1979 et la présidentielle de
1981 prenons maintenant le résultat de
la liste
lionel jospin de la liste socialiste là
encore le score du parti socialiste et
médiocres voire mauvais 20 8% des voix
on estimait que le seuil du très mauvais
score pour le parti socialiste était à
20% et bien on en est vraiment pas loin
du tout pour jean marie le pen enfin
cela confirme la réussite dont il se
targuait tout à l'heure elle est exact
c'est évidemment un très bon score pour
lui voilà je pense que maintenant on
peut prendre des comparaisons dans le
temps avec les deux élections qui
peuvent servir de référence pour
apprécier les résultats censés de 80 et
celle de ses jambes premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 1981 et
c'est le résultat de l'élection
européenne de 1979 alors commençons par
la liste simone veil donc nous voyons
aujourd'hui simone veil -le d'après
notre estimation obtient presque 42 %
des voix le total des voix obtenues par
monsieur giscard d'estaing michel debré
jacques chirac représentaient 47 9 % en
1980 et le total des deux listes
conduites par madame veil et par
monsieur chirac en 1979 représentaient
43 9 % 43 9 % quasiment 44%
c'était le score que madame simone veil
s'est elle même fixées pour comme seuil
de sa réussite
on le voit elle est en deçà de ce score
de réussite
à percé de monsieur jean-marie le pen et
la multiplication de petites listes
explique évidemment ce score très moyen
même un peu mauvais un peu décevant pour
elle de madame veil comparons maintenant
le les scores de monsieur lionel jospin
aujourd'hui encore une fois d'après
notre estimation et les scores précédent
des listes équivalente aux européennes
monsieur jospin aujourd'hui avec la
liste du parti socialiste 20 8% mais
sans les radicaux de gauche
monsieur mitterrand candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de 1981 25 8%
et la liste mitterrand aux élections
européennes de 1979 avec les radicaux de
gauche 23,4 pour cent alors évidemment
avec et sans les radicaux de gauche
entre 1979 et 1981 limiers 184 il y a un
argument pour mettre fin pour considérer
que il a simplement perdu laisse les
voix des radicaux de gauche
mais on ne peut pas en rester là le
parti socialiste et le parti dominant de
la vie politique française il à lui seul
la majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale et un score de 20,8 21% disons
pour arrondir à une élection au suffrage
universel et au scrutin proportionnel
c'est évidemment un échec
voyons maintenant la comparaison avec
pour la liste marché aujourd'hui
d'après notre estimation monsieur marché
obtient un peu moins de 11% des voix
c'est une nouvelle baisse par rapport à
1980 1981 marque est déjà une baisse par
rapport à 1979
voilà donc le parti communiste selon
laquelle qui d'après cette estimation
fait 10,8 pour cent des voix autant
n'est pas plus que jean marie le pen
aussi 18% des voix rené rémond un
commentaire sur véritablement ce
bouleversement de la carte politique
français ce soir c'est un bouleversement
et en même temps c'est un prolongement
un aboutissement dans le cas du parti
communiste c'est une étape de plus dans
le déclin et dans l'avé route puisque il
faut rappeler qu'il a perdu la moitié en
pourcentage de son électorat en six ans
si bien que quelle que soit la stratégie
suivie par lui ou ou associés au pouvoir
ou dans l'opposition ou pratiquant une
stratégie d'unité avec la gauche ou de
rupture hyper toujours il ya donc là un
phénomène qui passe en importance les
conjonctures successives
quant aux rapports entre la gauche et la
droite il est lui aussi bouleversé c'est
puisque l'addition des voix socialistes
et communistes fait un peu plus de 30%
et que les autres listes
il faudra y ajouter un certain nombre de
petites listes de gauche mais vrai
simplement pas beaucoup plus d'un tiers
de l'ensemble si bien que le rapport est
beaucoup plus bouleversé encore qu'on
l'attendait trois années d'exercice du
pouvoir par et savoir totalement utilisé
la majorité parlementaire
alors justement je crois que nous
pouvons voir maintenant de manière non
on ne peut pas encore voir ce que font
les petites vis
le sondage en tout cas je montre bien un
bouleversement en profondeur de de
l'échiquier politique français rené
rémond le disais à l'instant
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut noter c'est
évidemment
le grand problème politique qui va se
poser dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est celui des de l'écart qui sépare
l'opposition parlementaire rpr et udf et
la majorité parlementaire constituée par
une parti communiste et le parti
socialiste
cet écart est très important dix points
à peu près puisque la liste simone veil
la proche des 40 2% et la liste les
listes marché et jospin 32% alors
justement je vous propose de voir tout
de suite l'ambiance au parti socialiste
rue de solférino où se trouve dominique
laurie sis au siège du parti socialiste
on ne peut pas dire que l'ambiance soit
à la satisfaction
on peut dire que le champagne passe très
mal ce soit peu de commentaires du moins
pour l'instant à l'annonce du score ou
plutôt de la fourchette du parti
socialiste mais il faut dire les visages
sont plutôt fermé grande surprise
lorsque vous avez annoncé le score du
parti communiste mais le grand événement
ici très commentée c'est la forte
poussée de l'extrême droite
c'est le centre du débat surtout après l
intervention très musclée de jean-marie
le pen
désormais nous a déclaré un responsable
du ps et non des moindres la droite aura
besoin de l'extrême droite ce qui
modifie totalement la physionomie
politique française
un autre nous a déclaré madame veil
allié à jean marie le pen
quel problème de conscience je voudrais
pour conclure vous dire que lionel
jospin est actuellement en réunion et
que sa déclaration interviendra vers
vers 11h15 11h20 merci dominique laurie
alors revenons déjà sur sur les leçons
que l'on peut tirer sur les résultats de
ceux de ses estimations
c'est rené rémond jean marie le pen
lui-même il faisait allusion tout à
l'heure il faut bien rappeler que ces
élections européennes se sont fait à la
proportionnelle ce qui bien sûr donne un
facteur d'amplification optique liste
alors est ce que les résultats de ce
soir peuvent influer sur la réforme
électorale que l'on vit en cours de mise
au point
certainement
je suis moins certain que jean marie le
pen que nous voterons un seul tour à la
propre 786 celui l'april paris je me
garderai de de prendre le pari contraire
pourquoi le problème se pose-t-il parce
que on le sait françois mitterrand avait
pris l'engagement d'introduire une
certaine dose de proportionnelle
or nous en faire l'expérience de la
proportionnelle absolue c'est le mode de
scrutin le plus contraire à celui qui
assurait la victoire du parti socialiste
et qu'ils aient la majorité absolue dans
la présente assemblée
jean-marie le pen faisait observer je
crois avec justesse que un gouvernement
tient toujours compte des résultats
probants alors que ce que donne
l'expérience de la proportionnelle d'une
part elle affaiblit le parti de mineurs
car il suscite sur ses flancs des
concurrences de petites formations
ce n'est pas le péril majeur ce qui me
paraît en fait le plus important c'est
que le particules socialiste ne peut pas
bénéficier au second tour du report des
voix et que imaginons que effectivement
au vote à la proportionnelle
le parti socialiste aura un groupe
parlementaire mais ne récupérera pas
tous les suffrages communiste or ce sont
eux qui lui ont assuré la majorité
absolue en 1986 bien que je suis
beaucoup moins certains ce soir que je
n'était jusqu'à présent que la réforme
électorale introduira une centaine de
sièges qui seront répartis à la
proportionnelle pure et je pense qu'on
va s'acheminer vers un régime mitigé où
il y aura un peu de proportionnelle nous
conservera du majoritaire
voilà ils étaient donc fortement
question d'un panachage entre la
passerelle intentionnel et un système
majoritaire il n'ya fort à parier que
les ordinateurs du ministère de
l'intérieur ce soir vont tourner à plein
régime pour analyser de façon chiffrée
les différentes formules que soit le
mode de scrutin c'est en fait le corps
électoral ne se modifier pas d'ici deux
ans l'actuelle majorité perd la majorité
car contrairement à ce que vient de dire
un socialiste interviewé à l'instant
laurie madame veil n'a pas besoin des
suffrages de le pen pour avoir
l'avantagé sur la coalition des
socialistes et des communistes bien je
vous propose maintenant de refaire un
petit tour à l'étranger
en attendant que de manière visuelle
nous puissions poursuivre notre analyse
des estimations les bulletins de vote je
vous rappelle que les urnes sont
maintenant close depuis 22e
alors paul nahon est ce que on a des
chiffres un peu plus précis sur l'impact
de ces élections électorales sur la
majorité de même fait cher en
grande-bretagne alors les premières
estimations qui se confirme et nous
venons de recevoir une dépêche à
l'instant donne une courte victoire
conservatrice et une spectaculaire
remontée travailliste en grande-bretagne
via la grèce est ce que vous l'attendiez
longvic l'effet attendu attendu mais je
crois que c'est une difficile campagne
pour l'alliance l' alliance entre les
sociaux démocrates et les libéraux et
sans te qui fait les grands perdants
sent pas pour la plupart les
conservateurs mais est-ce qu'en grande
bretagne dans votre pays la campagne n'a
été aussi virulente qu'en france dix en
national non c'est une campagne morne
sans intérêt vous avez vu le taux de
participation allant de 4 à 30 ans à
savoir qu'un anglais sur froid s'est
déplacé pour voter c'est justement
personne ne s'intéressait aux élections
et c'est pour ça aussi peut-être sans
fin a été trahie mais ce que est ce que
les zombies ont voté sur des thèmes de
politique intérieure comme ici en fuite
tout à fait tout à fait leur un peu pour
l'instant surtout
le parlement européen il ne voit pas
pourquoi ça peut toucher une arrivée ça
n'a pas d'intérêt pour on va laisser
tomber votre pays je voudrais que vous
ne commentiez avec nous en tant
qu'observatrice un peu étrangère mais on
poste à paris les résultats français
oui justement vous avez vu tout à
l'heure jean marie le pen qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous britannique de 7 pouces
et sans précédent de l'extrême droite en
france à l'occasion était là je crois
que c'est lié un peu de ce que je viens
de dire que ce but jean marie le pen
était à mon avis était le seul qui a
fait une campagne qui a vraiment avec
des thèmes qui a vraiment touché les
gens dans leur vie quotidienne
il n'a pas parlé de la reconstruction de
l'europe et des idées un peu comme comme
ça qui sont un peu autrement dit vivre
l'élection européenne à condition
surtout comme tenta de l'homme un peu ça
oui je crois que c'est aussi bien pour
les français que pour l'exemple un
madame thatcher voulait pourtant
convaincre ses compatriotes que le rang
à la fête cher était le meilleur
argument pour défendre les intérêts
nationaux britanniques
mais l'europe à la thatcher ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire tout simplement qu'on
a finalement ce qu'on a demandé de tes
autres neuf c'est à dire une réduction
dans notre contribution
je crois que madame thatcher a fait
campagne sur la tête la voix forte en
europe
et si c'est bien elle et elle cessa déjà
comment analysez vous dînez guedes la
chute du parti communiste français vous
ou l'attendiez cette chute n'ont pas pas
jusqu'à ce point là j'ai j'attendais une
baisse mais pas jusqu'à sa fin si
spectaculaire mais je crois aussi là les
les gens en france en a marre de
l'hypocrisie des des partis politiques
je crois que c est ça aussi un peu l'un
des avantages du pagne il parle direct
noël oui mais et c'est là que c'est un
avantage parce qu'il tente directement
tandis ce marché il parle toujours il
donne l'appui au gouvernement mais
l'attaquant même temps ça pour moi c'est
une hypocrisie totale et c'est selon
vous cette ambiguïté qu'il fait chuter
oui je crois parce que les gens ne
me crois qu est ce qu il dit une
dernière question est ce qu une poussée
de l'extrême droite
comme on vient de le voir en france il
possible chez vous en grande bretagne
n'importe quoi est toujours possible
n'importe où mais je vois pas pour
l'instant je ne vois pas être de tout ça
on entend la voix à la proportionnelle à
l'angleterre et on n'a pas cette semaine
de ras-le-bol ras-le-bol que vous avez
en france les français ont pu voter sans
avoir peur dans ces élections sans avoir
peur que ça peut avoir un effet direct
sur cette ut vote pour un parlement qui
n'ont pas beaucoup de pouvoir c'est pas
une vente qui va relier qui justement
killer love on appelle ce que la grande
bretagne est effectivement le seul des
dix pays européens à ne pas voter à la
proportionnelle mais au suffrage
majoritaire à un tour alors nous sommes
maintenant en mesure et de revenir aux
résultats français et devoir maintenant
de façon précise les résultats des
petites listes mises à part les quatre
grandes glisses patricia jean nolet vous
avez raison christine de les appeler
petit puisque je vous dis tout de suite
il n'y en a pas une seule qui franchit
la barre des 5% alors la liste de
monsieur gauclin vous allez voir son
score tout de suite la liste de marc de
gauclin obtient 0,81 10 % trotsky la
liste d'arlette laguiller lutte ouvrière
obtient 2,20 % la liste de serge
depaquit ps eut qui faisait leaf
légalement avec monsieur fils bas les
communistes dissidents n'obtient que 0,9
pour cent
la liste olivier stienne celle donc la
liste r avec tyr dubaï lalonde obtient 3
5% et la liste de didier anger
il s'agit la liste du de la liste du
parti écologiste les verts obtient elle
3,5 pour cent donc même score pour la
liste air et puis pour la liste
écologiste
alors revenons maintenant résultats sur
personne petite folie on va pas les
oublier notant que le e non plus n'ont
pas franchi la barre des 5%
il ya donc la liste de
du fédéraliste européen henri cartan
mathématicien qui obtient 0,5 pour cent
la liste de francis gomez c'est sans
doute une déception pour elle elle
obtient 2,20 pour cent il n'aura donc
pas d'élu à strasbourg
la liste de gérard touati qui réunissait
des jeunes entre eux des jeunes
entrepreneurs 0.80 gérard nicoud tête de
liste des travailleurs indépendants 1,10
enfin la liste de jacques cheminade 0,2
pour cent voilà on a donc fait le tour
l'avait dit petit lit donc aucune je
vous le rappelle ne dépasse la barre des
5%
albert du roy vous pouvez maintenant
affiner les estimations sur les quatre
grands disent oui mais avant de les
affiner je voudrais vous citez cette
déclaration que vient de faire monsieur
jean lecanuet président de l'udf
monsieur jean lecanuet a déclaré je
souhaite que le président de la
république dissolvent l'assemblée
nationale vous savez que c'était l'un
des débats de la fin de la campagne
électorale
le secrétaire-général du parti
républicain françois lyotard avait
annoncé que si la gauche était
minoritaire aux européennes il
souhaitait cette dissolution mais
l'ensemble des grands leaders de
l'opposition à ce moment là et notamment
simone veil les bernard pons avait
écarté cette hypothèse en soulignant ce
qui constitutionnellement est évident en
soulignant qu'une élection européenne
n'entraînait pas de conséquence
automatique sur la vie institutionnelle
de la france donc l'agent le casier
présidente des réactions divergent des
avis récent ce demain veille et de nager
le débat le débat est clairement est
clairement relancé là il est évident que
monsieur lecanu et par rapport à la
veille à hyères à un argument de plus
c'est le l'énorme écart qui existe entre
la gauche et l'opposition dans l'est nos
estimations alors c'est l'estimation
justement gelé précise un tout petit peu
par rapport aux chiffres que nous avons
donné tout à l'heure tout à l'heure nous
vous donnions 10,9 pour cent 10 8% pour
monsieur marchait notre à thin man nous
conduit à 10 9%
pour lionel jospin notre dernière
estimation s'établit à peu près à 21,1
pour cent
pour madame veil un tout petit peu plus
que tout à l'heure
3 % pour jean marie le pen exactement le
même chiffre que tout à l'heure 10 5%
j'ajouterai rappelez-vous qu'en début de
soirée nous vous avons donné des
fourchettes à partir d'un sondage à la
sortie des bureaux de vote
l'estimation que nous vous donnons
actuellement sur les bulletins de vote
réels s'inscrit parfaitement et pour
chacune des listes dans les deux
branches de notre fourchette de tout à
l'heure cela indique la qualité du
sondage à la sortie des bureaux de vote
quand n 2 a donné est organisée avec
bull et avec bébé à ces chiffres
s'inscrivent en effet parfaitement dans
l'es4 fourchette je vous prie je vous
propose maintenant de voir tout de suite
avec serge me serais l'ambiance au parti
communiste ou plus exactement à
l'humanité serge me serais et bien il
est difficile de dire pour l'instant ce
que l'on pense ici de ses estimations
pour le moins catastrophique pour le
parti communiste dans la pièce où je me
trouve ici avec une quinzaine de
journalistes et bien pour les
collaborateurs de l'humanité qui s'y
trouvent c'est l'incrédulité d'autres
ont déjà pris la mine de circonstance
georges marchais est arrivé mais il ne
s'est pas montré il se trouve en ce
moment même en réunion avec le bureau
politique du parti communiste français
et doit peser les termes du communiqué
qu'il lira tout à l'heure sitôt connues
les résultats définitifs un dernier mot
il ya quelques instants
quelqu'un de l'entourage de georges
marchais m'a dit pour nous
13 5% ça irait encore mais au delà et
bien le silence qui a suivi en disait
long
pour l'instant l'absence de résultats
définitifs au siège de l'humanité on
s'inquiète surtout du score réalisé par
jean marie le pen oui je vous rappelle
donc d'après les toutes dernières
estimations qu albert du roy vient
d'affiner le parti communiste et
monsieur georges marchais obtiennent 10
90 % des voix voilà on vient de ma
portée de une de deux quotidiens
demain matin libération tout filtre bien
évidemment sur le choc le pen s'il a une
libération dès demain même titre à la
une du matin la percée de l'open une
autre percée cette fois en italie ponot
où il semble bien que la mort du
secrétaire général du parti communiste
italien enrico berlinguer a fait passer
son parti en toute première ligne
oui il nous vous le disions déjà tout à
l'heure vers 10h15 une dépêche nous
parvient le parti communiste italien
dépasserait la démocratie chrétienne
actuellement au pouvoir et devient le
premier parti d'italie à l'issue des
élections au parlement européen selon un
premier sondage projections de
l'institut de sondages doxa le pc
obtiendrez 32,9 pour cent des voix
contre 31,2 pour cent le parti
socialiste italien de monsieur bettino
craxi progresse légèrement et recueille
11,8 pour cent des voix bien en ovalie
c'était attendu vous l'attendiez ce
résultat on pouvait seule attaque et
c'est réellement la mort des reliques
oberlinger qui a servi de certainement
la mort d'eric aubin le gua à jouer
parce qu'il a été présenté pendant
plusieurs jours par tous les journaux
sans distinctions comme un homme honnête
correcte et ils étaient ses traits
connaissance dans un moment où la vie
politique italienne connaît assez des
scandales et a fait apparaître ses
lieder et donc sans parti comme un parti
intègre intéressant et donc je crois que
l'émotion a joué certainement
et c'est là est une réconnaissance
solidaire qui a disparu lui aussi un
d'une limite sur le résultat politique
n'est-il pas aussi la reconnaissance
d'un particulier italien réellement
heureux communiste surtout europe 1
parce que la différence du parti
communiste français et le parti
communiste italien est un parti européen
dans sa liste et présenter comme
indépendants